i didn't want to be gay and the main
voices in my head were just telling me
you'll get through this you'll get
through this the reaction to you coming
out was quite polarizing i'm never going
to please everyone i made that decision
because it's what i felt was best for me
and that was you know important to me to
make a decision in that time and space
in my life that i felt good with and now
colton is ready to share his life with a
very special someone fiance jordan brown
what in your mind makes the perfect
dream wedding it's a celebration and
it's supposed to be for your close
friends and family i think you know our
rule of thumb was just you know not um
having to introduce ourselves at our own
wedding so we just want to make the day
so special and intimate for
ourselves and it's our day to celebrate
and
do what we need to do and what's best
for us
has colton ever thought about children
were children always on your mind him
did you always want to be a father
growing up and is that something that
may come down the line
yeah you know it's it's funny because i
remember vividly in the second grade uh
we were having like a career day and
they were they were basically like hey
tell us what you want to be when you
want to be older like write it down and
i put nfl player and they sent me back
to my desk and they were like you know
choose something a little more realistic
so i wrote stay-at-home dad um because
that was sort of my second option so i
always felt like i was born to be a dad
i feel like i'm great around kids and i
definitely want a few of my own